[Music]
my next guest the talented comedian who
co-stars on franklin and bash on tnt and
he hosts the video gaming podcast the
indoor kids on the nerdist network
please welcome the very funny kumeo
nanjiani
[Applause]
[Music]
hey uh wonderful to be here
uh you know some people are too stupid
to have opinions you know what i mean
like they haven't earned that right
i'll give you an example i was talking
to this guy and a background i was
raised muslim
hold for applause
no no no no no no
it feels very patronizing now
i was raised muslim i'm strongly this
guy who was never muslim you know which
i realized it's sort of a weird way to
put it
but we were talking about the gender
inequality in saudi arabia you know the
gender inequality in saudi arabia and he
looks at me i swear he looks at me he's
like it's not really their fault kamal
the quran says women can't drive
yeah pretty sure the quran never said
that because if the quran had said women
can't drive cars
1400 years ago
i will be the mosque right now
so would all of you
if 1400 years ago if 1400 years ago the
quran was like someday there will be a
metallic box that will carry you
wherever you want this we predict and it
will have four wheels and you'll have to
put gas and it tells you how fast you're
going and you have a thing to control it
and women shouldn't drive it
i would be like i know two things for
sure
islam is the one true religion
and women shouldn't drive
glad you guys laughed at that otherwise
it sounds like a horrible speech i'm
giving
islam is the one true religion
women shouldn't drive
that's much worse
have you guys heard of this drug
cocktail called cheese like that's the
street name of it cheese i'm not making
it up i saw all these news reports they
were like there's a new drug it's called
cheese kids in the midwest are doing it
it's an epidemic it's a new drug it's an
epidemic
of a new drug
so i looked at what cheese is and cheese
is a mixture cheese is called medication
and heroin
so really it's heroin
it is mostly heroin
heroin is doing the heavy lifting
in that drug cocktail
not a new drug mostly heroin
i can't just sprinkle heroin on pancakes
and go i've made a new drug
i call it pan shakes
don't forget the special shake sauce
it's just maple syrup and heroin
not a new drug
i think the last actual new drug was
crystal meth which you had to make in
your bathtub and if you messed up while
you were making it everything would
explode and you would die
that's how dangerous that drug is just
trying to make it can kill you
and you make it just from stuff you get
at the store
to make cheese you still need to find
heroin
just do the heroin
you already have heroin
it is very powerful
just do the heroin
that's my message to you guys tonight
just do the heroin guys
don't get fancy
i love horror movies my favorite one is
the the thing the original the thing
from like 1980.
it's an awesome movie
it's a research facility in the middle
of antarctica and then stuff happens
and i was uh watching it and towards the
end of the movie there are three people
left and they have to decide whether
they're going to try and escape or burn
the whole place down to make sure the
monster doesn't get out i was watching
the movie with my wife and she looked at
me and she was like what would you do in
that situation
would you try and survive or would you
sacrifice yourself to save the rest of
humanity
yeah i'm never going to be in that
situation
i'm never going to be one of the last
guys alive i'm going to be the first guy
to die i die right away
i die so the other characters get to
find out that something weird is going
on
i'm on the autopsy table 20 minutes into
the movie his heart is missing that's me
i'm the setup
i bridge acts one and two
i go off alone to find the cat
there's a weird noise in this dark
corner i'll investigate ah dead
i never even find out that there were
monsters
to me the entire plot of the movie was
we're at a research facility and the
cat's missing
the end
you guys have been fantastic thank you
so much
that's hilarious
really funny
ladies and gentlemen